[Music]
elielton is because of momo at the time of the
clue does not mean nothing, that's understood
No, because you like the noise that you
Likes the church when people still
are stamped and what the delegate is
tell her
the purpose of this manifestation is threefold
Firstly, it called for
impunity second place to implementation
of public policies in communities
the poor in which the
women more exposed to this type of
third-party infringement
psychological support to victims
if the child sees inside the house there is a
violence even if it is not physical
psychological know the man until
it becomes a normalization of the
violence
so we're looking to break this
circle